what happened at the school with this
teacher this is hopefully
this was uh this is an isolated uh
incident beginning of last week
let's stop there you're ready yourself
to debate any any other professor here
anybody that wants to challenge you on
this
i visited bosnia as you know uh 10 as i
told you
so you know where this person is who can
put their mother down even more have you
ever seen that
yo mama yo mama yo mama soap
no no no no no you you still you're
still just dreaming about it
of course of course of course it is
unforgettable
uh trip tell us some of the highlights
for those who've never been to bosnia
what were some of the highlights of your
trip because that's where
we actually saw each other
well there were so many highlights in
the trip or from the trip uh first of
all
i was i visited bosnia as you know
uh 10 as i told you 10 years before that
okay and i was amazed as
at the level of transformation that has
happened today
or actually more than 10 years okay a
gap between both
and they have moved on with their life
yeah and they want to rebuild their
country they want to re-establish
themselves
so that was really um an amazing thing
to see
also another amazing thing is that
i noticed that the number of people who
practice the deem
has increased yeah okay
um now i don't want to
say that well it is below
what it should be above what it should
be
this is another discussion yeah but
i think it has improved and inshallah
this would be
a very good sign we need to be always
optimistic and we need to
to keep
moving even if it is a bit slow
yeah this is another thing
um another element of course
you need the bosnians
hospitability is something that is
outstanding
uh simplicity yeah it is also
uh outstanding despite the that they
went
through a very tough time yet they are
able
at least the muslim community okay i mix
with the muslim community
at least they are able to to maintain
their
good their simplicity despite the
difficulties they went
through of course uh the the nature and
the dunya
of course this is something else but for
the believer
is as the prophet sallam says
who is passing by a tree to rest for a
few minutes
and then he will just leave it so then
you dunya is nothing but like
that yeah have you had an experience to
have some raw milk since then
yeah raw milk you know actually you know
um the reason i ask you for the audience
that doesn't know that we have some
footage here
that people can see we actually you are
at the farm where are they i haven't
seen those
footages no we'll send it to you that
you're drinking some
me and you actually drinking some raw
milk yeah no
see i you know my first experience with
rome mel uh goes back to sudan
yeah so what happened maybe this was 25
years ago yeah 25 years ago
i was younger now people will say wow 25
years ago then how old is the
the other how old is the sheikh yeah i'm
still young alhamdulillah
yeah yesterday a person saw me
uh reading or holding a small mushroom
yeah and then he stopped and then he
said
are you able to read in this yeah i said
say masha allah
he said masha allah i said no say it
from your heart he said masha'allah i
said no it's not coming
from your heart let me check your heart
so i put my ear next to his heart to
check whether he was saying get it from
okay a class perspective from his
heart sincerely or not uh so
anyway 25 years ago uh some brothers
convinced us to go for you know a
hunting trip in sudan you know sudan is
known for that
they are where you hunt rabbits
and what is it that bird very nice bird
we call it habara in arabic and
another bird very very beautiful yeah
and that was the season for for hunting
so i said okay i'm not a person of
hunting but let us go
so we went and uh you know i took
some water clean water with me yeah
because i know that the people some of
the people around me they will not
they don't care yeah anyway so um
i took the water and they drank my water
so we ran out of water okay and then
i became really thirsty and it was like
dessert and it was hot in mud in sudan
so what happened they came next to
not a water well like
water gathering in in like a big
a big trench yeah big trench
and then they said oh no this is nice
water and they want to drink from it and
it is
mud man yeah mud mud
and they said yeah yeah it's very nice i
said
what this is not very nice anyway
they and then
i was thinking of drinking contemplating
drinking not
drinking and then just all of a sudden
i saw you know some insects is swimming
in the
uh we call it fusa i don't know the
black insect this that walks
and it is very disgusting and i saw it
swimming in the
i said no way that i can drink from this
water
then i saw like a farm person we have
had some cows yeah and then
i went to him and i said can i buy some
milk from you
yeah and then he uh which is the word
he milked that the cow and he gave me
some
raw milk when i i drank it
and then i i asked a friend of mine who
was who was a doctor he said
what you should not drink raw
milk raw cow milk before
boiling it otherwise you might get
you might get certain diseases so uh
this is my experience with raw milk yeah
but with goat
raw milk i had some experience about it
although
in the beginning it might not smell
nicely but it is
now for people that don't know you
actually and tell us about that before
we also talk to
talk about have many other questions but
i mean this is a very important topic
uh that you actually in your state you
had a battle of cancer
not too long ago did you at one point
feel like you were
this was it like you were tasting almost
death
uh well as you have said this this is
really an interesting point
at um i started to take the
chemotherapy and uh what happened is
that
subhanallah it is uh amazing that
the second dose was
uh so hard
so hard uh
but even before that let me just go
quickly before that because of time
after the first dose what happens is
that
there was hemorrhage internal bleeding
and uh so the doctor he said no we need
to keep you in the hospital
okay so uh they kept me in the hospital
but in the beginning they kept me in
light
while they are giving me the chemo is
like
a hotel that belongs to the hospital
they separated from the hospital because
of
maybe because of the chemotherapy etc so
uh in the middle of the night i woke up
and i felt that i'm going to die
yeah because the pain is unbearable
okay i have never experienced such pain
in my life
and then i said in the morning
early in the morning i will call my
brothers who live in saudi arabia
just to to organize maybe uh
finish my will i wrote my will
alhamdulillah
but maybe finish a few things because
that's it death
after this cannot be but death
and subhanallah in the morning i woke up
um to pray feder
and then i was making good and look what
happened
in the in the mirror okay i was making
guru
started to make udo i looked at myself
and then when i looked at myself
i said well actually this is not a face
of a person who is going to die
yeah and then i said okay come on man
just
kick out these ideas whatever allah
decrees
will happen to you so i didn't call even
my family
or my brothers in saudi arabia and i
continued
uh but that these days
i was yeah any feeling that oh it is
khalas
just just okay that's the end of me
before that also uh when
because i had the cancer first and then
they remove it and then
it came back again and then they removed
it and then
it came back the third time when it came
back the third time it was
very aggressive and i remember when i
checked it and the doctor had an mri
actually today i have an mri appointment
yeah just for regular checkup but at
that time when i had the mri
the specialist he told me that
the cancer spread yeah
in your shoulder and in this part
because the cancer was here
i may share some pictures of the
conscious
actually um and
the actually i was
maybe a for the last
one and a half years when i had it the
first time the second time
etc i was in a state of denial
because at that moment when he told me
that it has a spread
i really started to think
then that that's it okay
ah well this is the end of my life will
be coming soon
yeah because when uh it is cancer
stage three and four and the cancer has
started to spread and
well we i have heard a lot that after
cancer there is nothing but
death in most cases and it is the second
main reason for death in the world
so um kind of felt
that but alhamdulillah by the grace of
allah
and this is my message to the people who
are battling cancer
never ever give up yeah
never ever give up remain strong all the
time
and i would like to say i by the way
one of the benefits of this experience
is that so many people call me
asking me for moral support so many
people battling cancer
call me uh for uh you know
moral support and i say to them at the
end of the day
brothers and sisters all of us are going
to die
this is
this we don't need even to quote from
quran and sunnah but we caught from
quran and sunnah
and for like just to to boost our imam
otherwise this is a fact no one would
deny that
and sooner or later you are going to
die so when you have concept maybe
your death is getting closer to you
and that don't take it from a very
negative perspective and
you just lose hope okay take it from a
positive perspective
whereby you um uh
you should feel that you need to do more
good deeds
yeah repent okay
write your will okay uh fix your
relationship with others
if you have taken any things unjustly
give it back to them immediately before
when you are on your deathbed you can't
do these things
and actually i say to people this
is a good sign and this is a mercy from
allah
because effectively
is warning you before taking
your life you know uh
if i if i may say my brother-in-law
okay subhan allah had cancer as well
yeah
he had cancer maybe worse than my cancer
in the same period
and he was battling cancer all of a
sudden when he was battling cancer
his brother died without
any notification okay his brother was
healthy actually
he was spending good time with the
family they were
they had their honor his in-laws uh left
him
life that he doesn't feel well he went
to the toilet he came out
from the toilet he sat on the bed on the
sofa
and then he passed away no one was
expecting this
he was not expecting this they were
expecting his older brother to die
but actually he died before his older
brother without notification
when allah makes you ill
yeah brothers and sisters don't take it
negatively
this is a very good sign and
see you are allowing me just to talk
talk talk i
i don't mind you know that is speakers
one of their illnesses
is to keep talking
yeah you cannot control them so it is
tell us how there's some recent
developments we're hearing over here
of someone who's you know beloved to
close to two billion people in the world
this is the last and final messenger was
sent as a mercy to all of mankind to
everybody
and again there's in in uk is that right
uh can you tell us what's going on you
had a teacher
that was uh can you tell us about what
happened at the school with this teacher
this is
uh hopefully this was uh this is an
isolated
incident beginning of last week a
teacher in uh
back libatili is north of england
yeah okay he's a teacher in badly
grammar school
grammar school means one of the good
schools uh he called
the students i think um between the age
of 9 and 13
and in one of the classes he said to
them i would like to show you something
that might be offensive to some and
uh and then he showed them the
charlie uh hippo uh pictures
so called off the prophet salem of
course they are just
mocking themselves by putting those
pictures okay
but that here they it is symbolic that
they want to
mock the prophet
and in response to that okay uh the
child he was a very clever child
and he went to his parents and he told
them and then uh
actually a few children uh went to their
parents
sorry i should have said that a few
children went to their parents
and then the parents started to march
in front of the school yeah and then
slowly slowly this
issue became big and obviously the
the headmaster of the school came out in
the beginning he issued a press the
statement and then
the parents were not very happy of that
uh press
statement and the muslim community
started to
engage more and more and then the school
uh announced that they are actually from
the beginning the school they announced
that they are suspending the teacher
and then i think the recent thing is the
school issued an
apology and maybe suspended uh two or
three teachers maybe this is
the latest maybe it has happened uh
today
and uh generally speaking um the parents
uh have accepted their response
so far now see at this
what what happened but this might lead
to
uh the debate over uh
over freedom of speech because the
teacher said
under my value of speech of freedom of
speech
i would like to show these pictures and
by the way our
uh genius brother our intellectual
uh hamza zortos he is having a debate
tomorrow
without one of the professors from that
school
so
he's having a debate with a teacher from
that school no no no
no no no no with a professor i think
from youth uh
from america from america yeah okay
regarding
is it it has to do with this topic of
freedom of speech because it kicked off
because of what happened there with this
teacher
yeah over freedom of speech of course
you know
when anything uh happens okay uh
then uh this debate uh is
uh is uh is renewed and and many people
would like to discuss this and how islam
sees
uh freedom of speech yeah why why do you
why do muslims
those who submit their will to the
creator not the christian why do muslims
get so upset how would you answer that
when there's these things come up with
prophet muhammad yeah
okay uh
yes how can people watch this where can
they go to watch this this is tomorrow
okay so this is you know uh
brother hamza and ko they have
established a very
good uh think tank called
sapience institute okay sapience
institute maybe i don't know
so through that they can watch it i see
okay yeah yeah
so this one gotcha how free is freedom
of speech yes
yeah put it up a little bit up a little
bit there you go right there
how free is speech got it okay yeah okay
so anyway see
a few points here a few points first of
all
when they say when they say why muslims
uh become upset
first of all the question do human
beings become upset or not
yes to be honest with you you know i
found
that those who are debating over this
uh freedom of speech very simplistic in
their approach
i i i doubt their intellectual capacity
by the way and i'm i'm willing to wait
to debate anyone about this
okay so hold on let's stop there you're
ready yourself to debate any
any other professor here anybody that
wants to challenge you on this
yeah yeah of course of course because i
find that it is
over simplistic argument yeah
first of all do people become upset
sometimes
do you become upset or not that's the
part of the human makeup yeah certain
things
upset us of course so so why are you
asking me why do you become upset
at this so you should say why this in
particular
makes you upset yeah okay because
as if they will not become upset any
time this is one thing
the other thing is now
do you see things or do things happen in
front of you and you become upset
because
you see them yes of course
yeah when you see for example the other
day uh
so like uh a car running over a cat
yeah and the cat you know is is is
killed and is bleeding and
do you become opposite or not yes of
course
okay this is a human being nature so the
question here
is what makes you upset or what is
illegitimate to make
human beings upset and what is
illegitimate or
irrational or insane or wrong
to make human beings upset this should
be the question
yeah and we say that there are natural
things that will make you upset
and there are logical things that make
you
upset yeah and sometimes there's there
is an overlap between both of you
but between both of them for example
yeah yeah how is your son
yeah how is your son you we we met him
there yes
thank you for he's good yeah has he
finished
his yes yes he finished alhamdulillah
okay uh
sorry it reminded me of sorry i'm saying
yes yes i was sorry about to say hamza
okay so if i say to you um
what do you like me to call you abu
hamza or what that's
yes sure okay abraham say you know hamza
yeah he's such a stupid
uh boy yeah and uh
you know he is a filthy person
hey hey hey hey hey you're going to a
slow down now
and you know you don't you know about
your son what
i know about him i saw him the other day
doing this and that
now if i say to you listen guy why are
you upset
take it easy man it's fine i'm insulting
your beloved son
and calling him this filthy person and
that
and just you need to smile you don't
need to be a human being
you don't need to be a father yeah okay
and this is not your son don't worry why
you should just respond now am i asking
you for something
that is rational
no i'm asking you am i asking you just
to
i'm asking you not to act as a human
being
i'm asking you to act as a as a robot as
a
as a as a computer as a machine yes or
no
yeah let alone if somebody's insulting
your mother or somebody and you can go
down the line yeah
see the problem is when with insulting
your mother it is very unfortunate
non-muslims they don't value their
mothers as maybe they value their
children that's why
that's that's that's a good point
because they actually have your mama
contest
mother's teeth got more tarter than red
lobster
your mother so fascia honored clothes in
the driveway
your mother been on welfare so long they
put a face on a food stamp
so you know where this person is who can
put their mother down even more have you
ever seen that
yo mama yo mama your mama's so
ugly every time she look at the mirror
the mirror duck we got that over here i
don't know if they have that over there
i i haven't seen that yet but yeah i
changed this
because i noticed that when you people
when people say
for us as muslims your mother is the
most valuable thing
in your life yeah apart from your deen
of course
and if someone were to insult your
mother for us this is you go
crazy but it is very unfortunate that
the the status of mother has been you
know
uh watered down or diminished now or put
down
actually not just watered down yeah so
people
yeah so what if you are insulting your
mother that's why i
i make this example if i insult your
son and i call him stupid he doesn't
understand this and that
you will feel agitated yes then if i say
to you
no don't feel agitated no who is wrong
of course i am wrong i am the one who is
stupid i ask you
okay why don't you become angry now
the non-muslims as i said with with
mothers
they don't unfortunately see let me just
say this values are diminishing
okay and they've been replaced by fake
values that and the values that has been
replacing the natural human being values
are fake values that serve
the enter the the interest of of
of uh certain rich people
not the value-based people for example
who is talking about when when they talk
about
values and actually if if we want to
talk
intellectually about this subject we
should say
first the first question yeah before
uh insulting your mother insulting your
children etc
now when you say that a freedom of
speech is
a family is a value yeah who decide
okay who decides uh the values
whether they are values or not yeah the
virtues whether they are values or not
or principles whether there are values
or not
this is the question number one question
number two if
we say that well this side is the most
qualified maybe entity to to to decide
uh what values are then the details of
the values
yeah and here there is a huge a huge
misconception in the non-islamic west
because they don't have allah in their
life
what happens they just have the slogans
not values because values they need some
details
they don't have the details when you
talk to them about freedom of
speech they just they talk about the
freedom of speech
they don't have jurisprudence of freedom
of speech
so that's why they are not qualified to
talk about values
what who is qualified to talk about
values
is the one who is able to give okay
guideline for the details of such
values yeah and that's why we from an
islamic perspective
we have something called the of
the islam yeah of speech
yes or no yes yeah and the
is what they earned by their tongues so
the prophet saw asylum is giving us some
guidelines for what for freedom of
speech
okay so this is one thing which is a
very deep
philosophical point which goes back to
who decide what is right what is wrong
yeah so when we say this is right this
is wrong
who decides values is this a value
or not what are the details of the value
okay and so on so this is number one
yeah now point number two
uh see
okay imagine there is a value
okay imagine you have a value of freedom
of speech and you have that
uh the guidelines of that value
now if my value goes against your value
yeah what shall we do for example
if yeah if i insult you
and that annoys you does that give me
the right to insult you
just because i believe that it is a
value and then
i force my value on you i and i should
i said to you you should not be insulted
you should
smile look at this dictatorship
of worse than the dictatorship that we
see
in in the middle east okay this is like
intellectual dictatorship yeah that i
should
insult you i should put you down okay
this is the colonial dictator mentality
before it used to kill people
shed their blood yeah and they should
not
uh they should not object yeah even
i i remember that there was a story of
uh um you know one of the canola
colonial uh uh
soldiers yeah in one of the countries he
was
you know slaughtering slaughtering one
of the
indigenous people and then that
indigenous people he bit
his arm yeah okay and then he was
shouting and he was you know slapping
him such
a barbaric person and then he went to
his son
to to his uh colleague and he told him
look at those barbaric people
he bit he was about to cut my you know
flesh he said why he said i was
slaughtering him
so slaughtering him is not barbaric yeah
and when that person defends himself
this is barbaric
so same thing i should insult you put
you down
do whatever i want to do and you should
just respond by smiling
yeah in order to show me that you are a
civilized person
but i am not a civilized person on i
insult you okay
so did you get that okay
so here there is a debate
non-muslims who claim these values
they should have a debate among
themselves what about if there is a
value
and that is okay causing harm in the
society
should we continue doing this value
and by the way i find that this
as uh as a
big problem in the non-islamic world
yeah which is what they don't
care about muslim yeah they don't care
about
the benefit they care about one thing
only which is pleasure yeah
pleasure okay so that's why
if you know drinking alcohol is
damaging the economy of countries yes or
no
yeah okay uh here every 10 seconds
someone's dying from alcohol
i i was about to say the in in in the
in the u.s uh it is something yeah
every 10 seconds okay and the economy it
is damaging the economy you also
know even i was reading about some
statistics
regarding you know sarah edward that
was killed you know uh two weeks ago
uh here in in in london
and they were talking about the crimes
against women
and they said many of those crimes i
forgot actually the figure
many of the crimes maybe 60 percent
don't count me anyway
of crimes against women is due to what
alcohol alcohol yeah okay now
if we are talking about the rights of
women if we
are really talking about the rights of
women we should stop
people from drinking alcohol
yes or no okay but they don't want to
admit to that
and i'm sure now maybe we will leave
this uh
this once you put this online yeah there
will be
uh one of the the uh
which is it one of those uh right wing
uh
or maybe now even we have extreme
left-wing
you know uh newspapers and they will
accuse me of
seeing look what did he say he wants to
stop alcohol he wants
to ban alcohol yeah and they will
yeah but if you are talking about the
rights of women
okay go ahead protect women do something
to protect to
protect a woman all what they say that
well
we should criminalize uh
sexual harassment we should include in
sexual harassment
other things uh like looking
staring verbal abuse even sexual
harassment between
between uh between you know
within the family it is called sexual
harassment if i put
my hand on my wife yeah my halal
and she said oh this is sexual
harassment now
she can report me to the police okay let
alone
so-called raping okay or uh
other things yeah so they want to
criminalize this
okay or maybe maybe they will they would
reach to a level that if i send
a love message to my wife yeah i love
message to my wife or maybe
something kisses then oh ooh
this is you know sexual harassment they
where are we going and then are they
talking about
values okay and when they talk about
values
where are the family values okay
what what where are the family values is
anyone talking about
you know uh values in terms of the
elders
of the values in terms of my mother who
was cleaning my nappies she has no
rights
no place no value in the society
yeah my father who was working day and
night in order to
he was taking the food from his mouth
in order to give it to me and then the
society is not talking about
my value actually or such value
actually yesterday i was or the day
before yesterday i was with
a secondary teacher yeah and
it is unfortunately a state school but
most of them are
muslims one of the girls one of the
girls
she called the police yeah
because her father stopped the wifi
yeah and she was aiming she told this uh
this teacher she said she was aiming
that the social
services will be involved in order to
what
yeah to get the wi-fi back to get the
wi-fi
pretty soon it's going to be because uh
you took away my 5g you put me on 3g
well yeah you took my right
my father okay infringe what or what is
the word
my rights are we going down that line
and see okay if we are going down that
line
okay i'm giving the good news to the
western world
that is anti-islamic that is anti-human
values
okay if they continue going down
down that route they continue they are
actually
continuing to decline and destroy
themselves by themselves yeah
they don't need external enemies to
you know to destroy them they are going
to destroy their countries
and and our countries it is a very
unfortunate
and this is what uh uh i think fukuyama
have said
he said i'm not worried about america
from any external threat am i worried
about america yeah because of what
they break down of family
values wow tell me shake uh we got a few
more minutes how much time do we have
left with you i
want to respect the time i know you have
to go soon i want to get some
some quick rapid questions in yeah
questions
we have uh six seven minutes okay what
about
uh when jesus is insulted how do muslims
feel i mean
this per this mighty messenger who we
love and revere is one of the greatest
messengers
how do muslims feel there we as muslims
believe in all prophets we respect
all prophets and by the way we are proud
to that our deen that islam is the only
religion that believes in
all prophets and uh
respects all prophets and respect the
honor of all prophets
and this is a clear in the quran
minor
they believe in all the prophets and
they do not distinguish between
all of them in fact it is established in
our arcadia that if someone disbelieved
in jesus
or arisa let us call him isa because
there might be you know confused
confusion
isa prophet isa or prophet musa or
prophet abraham
or any other prophet then this person is
leaving the fold of
al-israel yeah so we should react in the
same way and we
do react in the same way yeah by the way
by the way our dean in general
is not a deemed to mock someone
yeah whether he or she whether he is a
prophet
or he or she they are normal people
yeah our deal is not based on mockery
honor the human beings and the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
who is our role model
[Music]
yeah he was not using bad
language yeah and the prophet sallam
says that the believer is not the quran
that who just insults and that's why you
know
there is this sect from islam without
mentioning them
you know everyone knows them they
their deen is based on insulting abu
bakr and umar and we say that
listen okay even if whatever the case
the first proof that your deen is
wrong is the fact that it is based on
what
on insulting okay
insulting others yeah uh
[Music]
yes okay second question
how can someone from the right from the
left the president up in the white house
anybody out there when we say that he
was sent as
a mercy to all the worlds how can they
confirm that what direction would you
point them
that they could substantiate that he
indeed was actually a messenger
for them also okay very good very good
we say that okay just leave your
emotions
aside yeah and just think rationally
this is islam this ah these are the
instructions the prophet saw asylum
provided us with
a check is there any instruction
that is harmful yeah
and moreover you will check that leaving
any instruction of or guidelines that
islam called for
is actually bringing home all of our
instructions
now it is very unfortunate that there is
no
uh intellectual debate regarding this
because if i ask this question people
immediately
ask about what yeah about yeah
but yes
they forget about everything and they
say well in islam
the thief okay should be punished like
this and the
the the the uh fornicator or the
adulterer or those who commit
homosexuality or those who did this and
that they will be
punished like this this is the only
thing they think about because this
proves
and when a person is discussing with me
and then he brings this he proves to me
that he is
ignorant of islam and not only that that
he is just following
the stereotyping because he just spoke
about these things
he did not look at the justice system in
islam
and it is one of the main foundations of
islam
allah
okay so the principle of justice justice
in the political level justice in the
social level so
justice in the financial level justice
even
against a human being justice against uh
old people the small people
against the humanity against
non-humanity against the trees the
environment
everything just not only that
but actually we have superiority we have
something called
this is above justice no one in the
world there is no
system in the world has that they might
have some
limited emotional mercy
limited emotional mercy but we have
mercy
and as a comprehensive system
yeah it is part of our system okay
what does that mean in court
okay if we have a dispute in court you
take your right i take my right
that's it however islam is saying
i say oh listen okay you are a friend of
mine
although jani i this is my right
i forgo you because you are my friend
let alone
my brother let alone my mother or my
father
yeah okay let alone my relative so this
is
forgiveness this is part of the system
even the leader of the community he has
to forgive
sometimes if there is no conflict yeah
when the person
repents and come to him so this is
this is yeah also
one of the unique qualities of of
islam which is a reflection of or a
manifestation of the rahmah
is the fact that see islam prohibits
us from committing certain crimes but in
order to
help us to stop those crimes
islam is stopping us from so many steps
before that yeah so for example
uh why islam is not allowing
nudity and commanding women to work
hijab
and commanding men to lower their gaze
why is this
in order to stop men from what
raping women yeah in order to stop
uh zina fornication or adultery
now why islam is doing that because
islam knows
that if we allow uh if we allow
zina fornication adultery there will be
illegitimate children
then there will be no safety because i
will be afraid that
my wife behind my back will cheat on me
and uh and i will have no trust
uh with my friends okay and this
will this this will dismantle the
fabric of the society so islam
said in order to maintain the integrity
of the society
we need to take number of measures
take this case of the murder of the sad
murder of
killing this lady sarah ever now
see they are talking about protection of
women
and you know you need to have a
comprehensive
system to protect women or men or any
member of these societies not just by
isolated laws
here and there this will provide
security for the see
for the the the system or the society dr
haytham is it a lucid clear hypocrisy
when you have a certain race for example
of people who are insulted
you can't hide behind freedom of speech
when people deny the holocaust
you can go end up in certain countries
you can go to jail and you can't hide
behind freedom of speech
when you criticize or you talk about or
you don't agree with
let's say a particular alphabet movement
same thing you can't hide behind the
freedom of speech
but now when you're insulting moses
jesus and the last and final messenger
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon them
all now people hide behind freedom and
speech
is this a clear hypocrisy of course this
is this is a sign of hypocrisy and this
is
a sign of you know that this is this
system
has so many flaws and it is impractical
and it is used as an against
uh it is used as a weapon against you
as muslim yeah but in reality it doesn't
exist
yeah and the last one how should muslims
when moses is insulted when jesus
is assaulted when prophet muhammed peace
and blessings be insulted when
when they are insulted how should
muslims react
yeah well see they should react
short-term term yeah and we should have
strategies to face
such yeah himself and
even we should you know as muslims
should on a long term uh march and
to the level that we reach to a level to
criminalize
okay to criminalize the
the the uh religion okay the symbols of
the religion
okay the religion that is what
that is widely accepted such as islam
such as christianity however
criminalizing this
doesn't mean yeah doesn't mean no
criticism
and people are conflating between both
okay
yes well criticize me as a muslim
uh regarding so many things in islam so
many things the prophet saws
etc and we are open for debate yeah
that's fine
okay um but just
in south mercury yeah that will create
uh more division and this will create uh
so many problems within within within
uh humanity yeah thank you very much
jazak lahaye thank you so much i know
we're out of time
thank you for spending some time with us
here on the dean show
no problem i am ready to to uh
to serve you at any time i am at your
service
and thank you guys for tuning in to the
dean show subscribe if you haven't
already hit that notification bell share
this program with
everybody that you know far and wide and
support us on our patreon page
thank you very much and as you've
learned jesus is beloved to our hearts
we love him
as one of the greatest messengers ever
sent to mankind moses
and the list goes on and the last and
final messenger prophet muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him look into his
life sincerely
what good will come out of mocking
insulting let us
go ahead and create more of a peace in
the world
through education through understanding
and that's what the dean show is
dedicated to
clearing the many misconceptions
delivering this message
and having helping you have a better
understanding of islam and muslims
you can actually call us if you want to
learn about islam you want to get to
know
who this messenger who was sent to you
and all of mankind's mercy to the world
call us 1-800-662-islam
we'll see you next time here on the dean
show until then peace be with you
assalamu alaikum
[Music]